MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Today we're talking
about database auditing,
multicloud fluency,
and enhanced customer
experience management.
I'm Mark and welcome
to This Week in Cloud,
where we serve you the
lowest latency news.
If you manage sensitive
data in your MySQL database,
you might be obligated
to record and monitor
user database activity,
especially if you
work in a regulated industry.
Cloud SQL for MySQL has
developed a new audit plugin
called the Cloud SQL for
MySQL Audit Plugin that
offers enterprise-grade
database auditing
to help you maintain a strong
compliance security posture.
You can now define audit
rules that govern which
database activity is recorded.
As IT footprints
get more complex,
you can expect to see a
broader range of cloud provider
requirements showing up
where you work and interview,
ready or not,
multicloud is happening.
And while multicloud fluency
is a huge opportunity
for an engineer, how do you
make the most of your time
and bandwidth to meet that goal?
Check out the blog for thoughts
on gaining multicloud fluency
and where to focus.
Sprinklr, the unified customer
experience management platform
for modern enterprises, has
partnered with Google Cloud
to accelerate its
go-to-market strategy
and grow awareness among
our joint customers.
To learn more about this
exciting partnership
and the challenges we
jointly solve for customers,
check out the recent
conversation between Google
Cloud's VP of marketing,
Sarah Kennedy, and Sprinklr's
chief experience
officer, Grad Conn,
or read the press release
on the partnership.
The cloud can be
complicated, which
is why we've been working
on helping Google Cloud
users with Active Assist.
It's a portfolio of tools to
help you optimize your cloud
usage and configuration,
with recommendations
around cost,
performance, security,
and even sustainability.
Check out the new
product page that
helps break down which solutions
you can get started with.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas, leave
us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.